Modulation is the answer to an embarrassing question:
a perfect radio wave says absolutely nothing.
A pure, steady carrier is just a hum in the spectrum — endlessly
repeating, perfectly predictable, carrying zero information.
To make a wave say something, you have to
change it.
Modulation is the art of changing a carrier wave in step with a message
— and every radio scheme in history is a variation on that one move.
Remember the three properties from the last chapter's write-up — a sine wave has an
amplitude, a frequency, and a phase, and those are the only things a transmitter can touch.
So there are only three families of
modulation.
Everything from nineteen-twenties broadcasting
to your phone is built from these three knobs.
Turn the amplitude knob and you get AM: the message is written into
the carrier's height — its envelope literally traces the audio.
Simple, but noise also lives in amplitude,
which is why AM crackles in a thunderstorm.
Turn the frequency knob and you get FM: the message speeds up and slows down the carrier's
wiggle while the height stays constant — so amplitude noise mostly wipes right off.
That constant envelope is why FM sounds cleaner than AM, and the third knob, phase, nudges
the carrier's timing — closely related to FM, and the foundation of almost everything digital.
Analog modulation varies the carrier
continuously.
Digital modulation makes one crucial change: it switches the carrier among
a finite menu of states, called symbols, each standing for one or more bits.
Shift between discrete frequencies and
it's FSK — frequency-shift keying.
Discrete phases: PSK.
Combine amplitude and phase levels: QAM.
Draw the menu as dots on a plane — amplitude out from the center, phase around it — and you get
the constellation diagram, the map every digital receiver uses to decide which symbol just arrived.
And here is the trade that shapes all of
digital radio.
More dots on the map means more bits per
symbol — faster data in the same bandwidth.
But more dots also means the dots sit closer together,
so it takes less noise to smudge one into its neighbor.
Fast-but-fragile, or slow-but-tough.
Wi-Fi at close range runs hundreds of points; a police
radio fighting fades across a whole city runs just four.
That's exactly what GopherTrunk spends its
life demodulating.
The land-mobile systems it decodes chose rugged, low-order schemes on purpose: four-level FSK — four frequency steps, two bits
per symbol — for DMR and NXDN, and a rotating four-phase scheme called pi-over-four DQPSK for TETRA and P25's simulcast flavor.
Once the signal is digitized, demodulation is just measuring amplitude,
frequency, and phase — the same three knobs — and mapping them back to bits.
So: modulation turns a mute carrier into a messenger, there are exactly three knobs to
turn, and digital radio is a menu of symbol states traded off between speed and toughness.
Full write-up linked below.